We seem to have some users that
either by mistake or on purpose
are signing up with email addresses
that don't exist or are not theirs.
This issue's made worse by the fact that
we've associated Google login emails
with the email password
logins that the user enters.
This is starting to look
like a major security issue.
Here, let me show you.
All right.
So here's Walter.
And here we have an evil hacker.
Let's say that Walter
logs in with Google and
that his Google account is
associated with his Gmail account
which has the address
americanguyw1521@gmail.com.
When this account was created it
also creates a user in our database.
So he logs in and he's all happy and
he makes some shopping lists.
Okay, so the hacker figures out
Walter's Gmail address because
maybe Walter isn't too
shy about sharing it.
He puts it up on a social networking
site or something like that.
And then what the hacker does is he
makes an account through email and
password, that uses
the same email address.
And with how we've set things up,
he can still choose whatever password he
likes and it's fine for
him to use this email.
Because the real Walter never made
a user in fire base with an email and
password, just with Google.
With the code as it is now.
These two accounts here are associated,
and they are considered
to be the same user.
So the hacker has now essentially
gotten into Walter's account
because the same email
address was used for both.
And all those new permissions that we
added such as only the owner can change
the name of the list, or
only the owner can delete a list
are meaningless because well, the hacker
has gotten into Water's account.
So he can rename Walter's
list as much as he likes and
poor Walter is powerless
to do anything about it.
As we start writing more code related to
ownership of the app, Walter is going to
get the ability to make lists that
are private to himself, but with this
security flaw, a hacker would be able
to see all of Walter's items and lists.
Now you might be saying let's
unassociate the two email addresses.
But this would still leave an issue that
the hacker could enter the account and
sort of masquerade as Walter.
It would also mean that Walter could not
use his own email address if he ever
decided to make an email
password provider user.
So I think a better way to go about
this is to try to think of a way that we
can have the user prove that they
actually own the email address
that they've put in.
To do this,
you could employ a creative use of
Firebase's password reset functionality.
Here I am in the Login and off tab.
And if you scroll down,
you'll see the section that's
all about password resets.
In your code, you could trigger for a
user to receive a password reset email.
And here's where you can configure
what that email will will look like.
You can configure things like what
the subject of the email will be
or who it's from.
And if you scroll down
a little bit more,
here's the actual body of the email.
Now, this includes a token string and
this token string is
basically the reset password
that is generated for your user.
So with all of this in mind, here's
the new flow that I'm thinking of.
First, when the user signs up, they'll
no longer be asked for a password.
Instead, the screen will just
take their email and their name.
This is the information that will
be used in the call to create user.
We'll generate a sort of dummy password
that we're going to throw away pretty
quickly, because if creating
that user is successful,
we'll immediately reset the password
using the resetPassword method.
Immediately after
resetting the password,
an intent will open
the user's default email app.
Now, resetPassword is the method that
triggers that email to be sent to
the user and it uses the email
address that they entered here so
as long as they're connected
to the Internet they should
see that first email in their email
inbox is the password reset email.
And they can go ahead and
open that email and
get a randomly generated password.
They can then copy the password
that's in their email and
navigate back to the app.
When they return to the app instead
of seeing the create account activity
screen instead they'll see
the log in activity screen.
And we can even be nice and
pre populate the email up here with
whatever email they originally gave us.
Then if we instructed them
to copy the password here,
they could paste it here and sign in.
And for now,
the first time that the user signs in,
we can actually use fire
bases change password method
to then change the random password
that was originally generated for
the user, to the reset password
that they just put in.
And then this way we can
confirm that the user
at least has access to the email
account that they put in here.
Okay, now this is by no means perfect.
For one, it makes the reset password
the user's permanent password, and
the reset password's
fairly hard to remember,
it's just some sort of random
string of numbers and digits.
Also, when you call
the resetPassword method,
whatever password is generated
only works for 24 hours.
So there is a scenario where
a user could create a new user,
get the reset email and
then get busy and decide not to sign in,
and then try to sign in after 24 hours
and lose access to their account.
But for beta version 0.3,
I think this is a pretty good flow, and
it does remove the most glaring security
flaws of our current login process.
Okay, so let me quickly show you these
two methods that are new to you.
The reset code is
pretty straightforward.
Just like everything else that we've
been doing with authentication,
you should grab a Firebase ref.
You can then code reset password
on that Firebase ref, and
all it really needs is an email
address that's in the system,
which means an email address that
you've called create user with.
If this reset password call is
successful, it will send an email and
take it here, and if it's not successful
you'll get the error down here.
This might happen for
example if you put in an email address
here that doesn't exist in the system,
you'd get the user does not exist
error that we've talked about before.
When the user signs in for the first
time, you call change password method.
This will take that same
email address of the user,
as well as the old password and
the new password.
You can use the reset password for
both of these.
Now you should only change the password
if this is the first time
that the user is logging in.
I'll leave it up to you to decide how
to check whether the user has logged in
before or hasn't logged in before.
And if you forgot why calling
changePassword is important,
it's because the users reset password
that they received in their email
is only valid for 24 hours.
Now if Shopping List Plus, Plus was
going into production immediately,
what I'd have you do is
create some extra screen so
the user could change their
password from the reset password
to something that they could
memorize a little bit easier.
But, again we'll start with this.
Okay the full spec is on the way,
so good luck.